Selamlar güzel arkadaşım. Elvin'in
yorumuyla başlıyorum. Her zamanki gibi
buradayım. Ankara'dan selamlar demiş.
Ankara'ya ve Elvin'e selamlar. Hocam
keşke ne zaman kaç video geleceğini
bilsek program yapıyorum da demiş.
Arkadaşlar önümüzdeki 2 3 bazen 4 günlük
süreci sürekli internette internette
diyorum Instagram'da hikayelerde
paylaşıyorum. Ben de inanın programı tam
olarak böyle yetiştirebildiğim ölçüde.
Çünkü bazı günler iki tane
çekebiliyorum. Bazı günler bir tane
çekebiliyorum. 49 günde TYT kampımız
devam ediyor bir yandan. onlara
videolar, orijinali soru çözümlerini
yapıyoruz bir yandan onlara bir yandan
videolar yetiştirmeye. Yani şu masanın
başında bilin ki Mehmet Hoca yaklaşık 8
ile 10 saat aralığında hiç kalkmadan
tabii özel ihtiyaçları hariç onun
haricinde hep video çekiyor. Sizleri
yetiştirmeye çalışıyor ama gün içinde
gelecek videoları öğrenmek için mutlaka
Instagram'dan takip edin. Hocam orijinal
yayınlarında beceri temelli soruları
gelince zorlanmam normal mi?
Zorlanmazsan problem var demektir.
Zorlanacaksın ki yavaş yavaş seviye
yukarıya çıkacak. Yapamadığın sorular
olacak. Bu gayet olması gereken noktadır
arkadaşlar. Tamam mı? Bu da tamam.
Teşekkürler hocam. Kıvırcık burada
demiş. Ela'ya selam olsun buradan. Şimdi
birçok yorum daha da gelmeye devam
ediyor. Ben de elimden geldiğince her
gün yorumları cevaplamaya devam
ediyorum. Neredeyiz hocam? En son ne
yaptık seninle birlikte? Sayı
kümelerinin özelliklerine girmiştik.
Daha bitmedi sayı kümelerinin
özellikleri devam edecek ama arada bazı
bağlaçlardan bahsetmem gerekiyor. Mantık
konusundan bahsetmem gerekiyor. Sayfa
48'i açıyorsun. Ben niye değiştiriyorsam
sayfa 48'i açıyorsun. İki sayfalık bir
kısmımız var. Burayı birlikte
bitireceğiz. Matematiğin sözel olduğu
noktalardan birine geldik. Hani
öğrenciler çok sevmez burayı. Ne yalan
söyleyelim. Bizlerin de çok öyle bayıla
bayıla anlattığı yerlerden biri
değildir. Ama gel buna yine biz tatlı
sohbetimizle senin de benim güler yüzün
diyelim inşallah senin de o tatlı
sohbetinle birlikte tadına vara vara bu
konuyu da halledeceğiz. gönder gelsin
dedi. Mantık şimdi.
Mantık nedir hocam diyeceksin ama
mantıkla başlamıyoruz aslında. Başka bir
şeyin tanımıyla başlıyoruz. Tanımımız
şununla geliyor. Doğru ya da yanlış
kesin hüküm bildiren ifadelere bundan
sonra biz ne adını vereceğiz
matematikte? Önerme adını vereceğiz.
Önermeler. Tamam mı? İlk şeyimiz, ilk
başlığımız aslında bir nevi önermeler.
Doğru ya da kesin hüküm bildirecek.
Bugün günlerden salı. Sen hangi gün
izliyorsun bilmiyorum ama ben bunu
söylediğimde günlerden salı değilse
yanlış bir önermedir ama önermedir.
Herkes aynı şeyi anlıyor çünkü. Tamam
mı? Ben çok baby face bir adamım. Sence
öyle mi? Belki sana göre öyle. Belki
öbürüne göre öyle değil. Herkese göre
değişiklik gösterebiliyor mu?
Gösterebiliyor. O zaman nedir bu? Bu bir
önerme değildir. Herkesçe o cümleyi
duyduğunda şunu hissetmesi lazım. Doğru
ya da yanlış olsun. Far filler uçamaz.
Doğru ya da yanlış ama hepimiz aynı şeyi
anladık. Filler uçuyor, kanatlarda
uçuyor gibi hayal ediyorsun, değil mi?
Aynen öyle işte. Yani doğru ya da yanlış
sana kesin hüküm bildirecek. Peki
önermeler doğru ya da yanlış ayrımı
yapıyorsa demek ki ne diyorum ben? Bir
önerme ya doğrudur ya yanlıştır. Arada
bir yerde kalamaz. Bir önermenin
hükmünün değiştirilmesi ya da doğruyken
doğruyken yanlış hükmüne yönlendirilmesi
ya yanlışken doğruya yönlendirilmesi ile
oluşan yeni önermeye o önermenin değili
adı verilir. O önermeye değili denir.
Olumsuzu denir. Oum. Dur şöyle yazalım.
Olumsuzu denir. Daha güzel olacak
buraya. Olumsuzu denir. Tamam mı? O
önermenin olumsuzu adı verilir. P
önermesinin değilini. Hadi olumsuzunu
şöyle iki tane yazayım. Sonra demeyin
değili nereden geldi? Olumsuzu değili
aynı şey. P önermesinin değili dediğimde
üstüne şöyle çizik atıyoruz. Bazen önüne
şöyle dalga işareti de bırakabiliyorlar
arkadaşlar ama üstüne çizik daha doğru.
Daha doğru demeyelim daha yaygın. P
önermesi doğru ise o önermenin doğruluk
değeri 1dir. O önerme eğer yanlışsa
doğruluk değeri 0dır. Tıpkı bilgisayar
kodlamalarında aslında ilerleyen
derslerde algoritmaya geçtiğimizde
buradaki mevzuya dönüyor. Ya doğrudur ya
yanlıştır değil mi? Doğruysa 1 yazıyor,
yanlışsa 0 olarak kodluyor. Şimdi hep
dedik ya bu özel ders kitabı aslında.
Şimdi buradan hemen alttaki bağlaçlara
geçmeyeceğim. Yan taraftaki soruyu
çözeceğiz beraber. Aşağıdaki ifadelerde
önerme olanların yanına tik atacağız,
olmayanlara çarpı atacağız. Gel bakalım.
Mehmet 5 harfli bir isimdir. 1 2 3 4 5 6
harfli. Hocam yanlış. O zaman bu bir
öner. Bu bir önermedir. Herkes aynı şeyi
anlıyor. Herkes aynı şeyi anladığı için
biz buna bir önerme adını veriyoruz.
Diyelim ki bu önerme P önermesi ise
böyle denktirle gösteriliyor. P denktir
0 diyoruz ama özünde bir önermedir.
Nasıl bir önerme olduğunu nereden
anlıyorum? Buradan. P0'a denkmiş. 1 yıl
12 aydan oluşur. Doğru mu? Doğru. Ama
hepimiz aynı şeyi mi anlıyoruz? Onu
söyle. Bu bir önerme mi? Evet. Bu bir
önerme. Diyelim ki bu Q önermesi olsun.
Q önermesinin doğruluk değeri 1dir.
Devam ettim. Kuş Adası en güzel turizm
merkezidir. Ben Kuş Adasında yaşıyorum
arkadaşlar. Doğuma büyüme İzmirliyiz ama
Kuş Adasında geçti ömrümüz. 8 yaşından
beri buralardayız arkadaşlar. Kuş Adası
en güzel turizm merkezlerinden biridir
bence. Ama bence sana göre belki öyle
değil. Belki sana göre Sinop. Vallahi
Sinop da efsane bir yer. Sinop'a gidince
anladım ben de yani. R denktir. R de
hayır R falan yok abi. Bu bir önerme
değil. Herkes aynı şeyi anlamında. Bu
bir önerme olmadığı için yanına çarp
attım. Bugün hava çok güzel hocam. İşte
güneşli ya. Çok güzel hava var arkadaş.
Belki sen güneşli seviyorsun. Adam
yağmurlu seviyor. Ne yapacağız? Belki
ben karlı seviyorum. Ne yapacağız? Heh.
Herkes kabul olması. Ha güzellik neye
göre güzel? Belki ben fırtınalı
seviyorum, parçalı bulutlu seviyorum.
Bilmiyorum yani. Bir gün 25 saat değil
değildir. Tamam bu R önermesi
diyebilirim ama bu R önermesi yanlış bir
önermedir. Ama kesinlikle bir önermedir.
Hemfikir miyiz bu konuda? Güzel. Şimdi
gel 74'ü de beraber çözelim. Aşağıdaki
önermelerden doğru olanların yanına D,
yanlış olanların yanına Y yazacağız.
diyor ki bunlar birer önerme. Sakin ol
şampiyon diyor. Sadece doğru mu yanlış
mı bana onu belirle diyor. En küçük tam
sayı 0dır. En küçük tam sayı kaçtır? Tam
sayılar eksi sonsuza kadar gider. En
küçüğü en küçüğü yoktur. O zaman bu
nasıl bir şeydir? Yanlış bir önermedir.
İstersen yanlışları kırmızıyla yapayım
da nasıl önermeler olduğu çıksın. Tamam.
Devam. İki tek sayının toplamı çift
sayıdır. Aklına gelen herhangi iki tek
sayıyı topla. Toplamı ne yaptı? 4 çıktı.
Çift sayı mı çıktı? Çift sayı çıktı. O
zaman bu kesinlikle nedir? Doğrudur.
Devam ettik. -2 karesi 4. Tamam da o
parantez kime ait? Hiç kimse ait değil.
Eksi tek başına takılıyor. 2nin karesi
4. Önündeki eksi kalır. -4. Kusura bakma
bu ifade yanlış. Üst sayıyı bilenler
hemen yaptı zaten. En küçük asal sayı
kaçtır? Tabii ki 2'dir. Hocam o zaman bu
değil. Yanlış. Bu ifade de yanlış. E
bitti bu kadar. Şimdi gel bakalım. Artık
bağlaçlara geçebiliriz. Bağlaçlarla
ilgili bilmen gereken yegane şeyleri
vereceğim. Ne eksik, ne fazla? Ne olur
fazlasına da gitmeyin. Gerek yok
arkadaşlar. Şimdi veya bağlacı, V
bağlacı ya da bağlacı. Bir de bir de
gerektirmeler var. Biz toplamda 5 tane
sayabiliriz aslında bunları. İse
bağlacı, ancak ve ancak bağlacı. Tamam
mı? Bağlaçlarımız 5 tane ama bunlar aynı
zamanda birer gerektirme. Veya ve ya da
ise ancak. Ancak. Şimdi bunları daha iyi
anlaman için ben sana örneklerle
anlatacağım. Tamam mı? Şuraya iniyorsun
kitabından. Tamam mı? Önce veya
bağlacından başlıyoruz. Örneğim şu: Ali
veya Ayşe gelsin dediğimde
ikisi birden bir gelmeleri olsun, 0 da
gelmemeleri olsun. İkisi birden geldiği
için öğretmen kızmaz. [iç çeker] Ali
veya Ayşe gelsin dediğimde Ali gelip
Ayşe gelmezse öğretmen yine kızmaz.
Neden? Ali veya Ayşe demişim.
Ali gelmeyip Ayşe gelirse yine kızmaz.
Ali veya Ayşe gelsin buraya dedim de
ikisi birden gelmezse gömürür. O zaman
bu durumlarda cevap 1dir. İşleme
aldığımızda diğer durumda cevap 0'dır.
Bunları ezbere bilmenize gerek yok ama
bilin de gerek yok ama bilin de ne olur
ne olmaz. Sağı solu belli olmaz. Geldim
V bağlacına. Şimdi bu arada veya
bağlacına bakalım. Bileşenlerden en az
biri doğru iken diğer durumların hepsi
diğer durumlarda yanlıştır. Bak
bileşenlerden bir tanesi bile doğruyken
cevap hep doğru. Diğer durumda cevap
yanlış. Bileşenlerden en az biri doğru
iken doğru diğer durumlar da yanlış ki
tek bir durum kalıyor. 0'a 0 0 veya 0 da
yanlış. V bağlacı. Bileşenlerden ikisi
de doğru iken doğru diğer durumlar da
yanlış. Anlat bakayım hocam bunun da
hikayesini. Ali ve Ayşe gelsin dediğimde
Ali de Ayşe de gelirse kızmam. Ali gelip
Ayşe gelmezse ben ne dedim size derim.
Ali ve Ayşe gelsin dedim derim. Tamam
kızdı. Ali gelmeyip Ayşe gelirse yine
kızdı. İkisi birden gelmezse duble kızdı
falan. Ama tek ne zaman doğru? İkisi de
1 olduğunda doğru. Diğer durumlarda
yanlış. Yani içinde bir tane bile 0
varsa V bağlacında cevap 0. veya
bağlacında içinde bir tane bile varsa
cevap daima 1dir. Şimdi Ali, "Ekmek ya
da süt alıp gel buraya dedim. Tamam mı?
Ekmek ya da süt alıp gel dedim. İkisini
birden alır gelirse kızarım ya da
bağlacı. Gösterim budur.
Ekmek ya da süt. Ekmek alıp süt almazsa
kızmam.
Süt ekmek almayıp süt alırsa kızmam.
İkisini birden almazsa kızarım. Ya da
Ali ya da Ayşe gelsin. Ali ya da Ayşe.
Yani birini çağırıyorum aslında. Sadece
bir tanesi doğruyken doğru. Diğer ikisi
birden doğru ya da ikisi birden yanlışsa
yanlış. Hangi bağlaçtan bahsediyorsun
hocam? Ya da bağlaşından. Bileşenlerden
sadece biri doğru ise doğru diğer
durumlarda yanlıştır. Bu hikayeleri
aklında tutarsan bir de şuradaki tabloyu
aklında tutarsan bu iş tamamdır. Geldim
hisse bağlacında iki önermeden birincisi
doğru. İkincisi yanlışken yanlış diğer
durumlarda doğrudur. İse bağlacısının
tablosunu aklında tutmanın en kolay yolu
da şur ise 1 1 ise 0 0 ise 1 0 ise 0
1'dir. Tamam da nasıl aklımda tutacağım
hocam? Şunu aklında tut. 100
yazabiliyorsun ise bağlacı. Diğer
durumlarda 100 yazamazsın. 1 1 0 1 0 ona
da 1 0 yazdığımda 100'e tamamlanabiliyor
mu? Tamamlanabiliyor. O zaman 0. 100
durumunda sadece 0. Diğer durumlarda 1
ise bağlacında böyle geldim. Ancak ve
ancak bağlacı. Önermelerin ikisi de
ikisi farklı ise yanlış. Diğer
durumlarda doğrudur. Bak bu ya da
bağlacının tersi gibi hayalet. Ya da
bağlacı yalnız biri doğruysa doğru.
İkisi birden doğru ya da ikisi birden
yanlışsa yanlıştı. Ancak ve ancak
bağlacında ikisi birden doğru ya da
ikisi birden yanlış iken doğru biri
farklı diğerindense yanlış oluyordu.
Güzel. Şimdi şunu söyleyeceksin. Eminim
aklından da şunu geçiriyorun hocam.
Affedersin ama bu olmadı galiba. İnan
biz bunları fazla kullanmayacağız ama ne
olur ne olmaz cebat dediğimiz
noktalardan biri burası. Şu önemli ama
şunla bir helalleşelim seninle.
Niceleyiciler iki tane iki tip
niceleyicimiz var arkadaşlar. Biri her
niceleyicisi, diğeri bazı ya da en az da
denebiliyor buna. niceleyicisi. Her
niceleyicisi evrensel niceleyicidir.
Yani herkes dediğimde alayını
kastediyorum. Bir kişi bile eksik
olamaz. Bir tanesi bile yanlış yapamaz.
Bu şuna benziyor. İnşallah sınavdan her
soruyu doğru yapacaksınız. Üniversite
sınavına giderken her soruyu dediğimde
ne anlıyorsun? Hiçbir yanlışım olmayacak
anlıyorsun. Güzel. Matematikte en az iki
yanlışım var hocam. Dediğinde bak en az
sembolü burada kullanılıyor. İşte en az
sembolü bir tane de olabilir, iki tane
de olabilir, 3 tane de olabilir. En az
iki tane garantiyiz orada. İki veya daha
fazla yanlış yaptım demek istiyorsun ama
en az bir tane var. Yani bir tanecik
bile olsa var. Yani en az bir tane
yanlışım vardır ya. O zaman en az bir
tane yanlışım var. Mesela bunu
anlıyorum. Biri varlıksal yani bak 1 2 3
gibi varlıksal. her evrensel alayını
kastediyor. Anlaştık mı? Bu bağlaçları
bilmemiz lazım. Yazılışları da önemli.
Biri ters A ile yazılıyor, diğeri ters e
ile yazılıyor. Her bazı en az anlamına
da geliyor. Tamam mı? En az 1 diye de
bazen okunabiliyor. Mesela en az 1, en
az 3 gibi. Şimdi geldim. Bazı
sembollerin değillerinin aşağıdaki
tabloda yazılımını beraber yapacağız.
Hani az önce ne demiştik biz? Bir P
önermesinin doğruluk değerinin
değiştirilmesiyle elde edilen önermeye o
önermenin olumsuzu değili denir ve bu
şekilde gösterilir dedik. Doğruluk
değerini değiştiriyoruz. Mesela 1 gün 25
saattir. Değilini alıyorum. 1 gün 25
saat değildir. 1 gün 25 saat değildir.
Şimdi böyle yazınca ne oldu? Değildirini
almış oldum. Değilini almış. Değildir ne
ya? Değilini almış oldum. Ama ola ki
matematiksel semboller geldiğinde nasıl
değiliğini alacağız hocam? Cümle olarak
sonuna değili yapıştır bitti. Tamam mı?
Matematikte ne yapacaksın? Eğer ki şu
sembollerden biri kullanıldıysa şöyle
yapacaksın. Değilini alırken. Her yani
evrensel niceleyicinin değili varlıksal
niceleyici yani bazı ya da en az
dediğimiz niceleyici. En az ya da bazı
niceleyicisinin değili herdir. Eşittirin
değili nedir? eşit değildir. Eşit
değildirin değili nedir? Değildirin
değili yine kendisidir. Yani pardon
değildir eşit. Değildirdeki değildiri
kaldır. Ne oldu? Eşittir oldu. Burası
kritik. X sayısı 25'ten büyük eşit
gözüküyor. Ya soru şu olsaydı x 25'ten
büyük eşit değil. Şimdi bak normalde x
25'ten büyük eşitse burayı karalarsın.
Değil dersen nereyi alırsın? olmadığı
yeri tümleyen kümesi gibi hayal et
burayı. Ha 25'ten küçük oldu o zaman
hocam. Aynen öyle. Büyük eşittirin
değili küçüktür. Aynı mantıkla
küçüktürün değili büyük eşittir. Küçük
eşittirin değili büyüktür. Hem yönü
değişiyor hem de eşitlik durumu varsa
kalkıyor ya da yoksa geliyor. Anlaştık
mı? Bu değildirler önemli. Birazdan
bununla ilgili örnek sorular çözeceğim.
Peki hocam biz az önce mantık
sembollerini gördük. mantık konusu adı
altında. Aslında bu semboller normalde
kümelerde nasıl kullanılıyor? 0
arkadaşlar varlık sallayiceliği pardon
boş kümeyi ifade eder. Yokluğu ifade
eder. Kümelerdeki karşılığı o da hani 0
1 doğru ya da yanlış anlamına geliyordu
ya. 1 doğru anlamına gelen sembolik
mantıktaki ifade kümelerde evrensel küme
anlamına gelir. Hani evrensel küme
yapıyorduk ya bir tane. Bütün işlem
yaptığımız kümeleri kapsayan en büyük
küme diye geçiyorduk. Hatırlıyor musun?
Ben sana V pardon A kesişim B'nin
tanımını yazarken A kesişim B'nin
tanımını yazarken şöyle yazdım. X'lerden
oluşacak hocam. Öyle ki X elemanı olacak
A'nın ve X elemanı olacak B'nin. Artık
ben bunu mantık sembolüyle göstereceksem
V diye gösteriyorum. Değil mi? Bak V
mantık sembolü ama nerede kullandım ben
onu? Kesişimde. Demek ki V'nin küme
sembolü kesişim anlamına gelecek. veya
A'nın. E hocam bak biz bunları
kullanmışız aslında. Evet çaktırmadım
ben sana. O bağlaçları kullandım. X
elemanıdır A veya X elemanıdır B
yazdığımda bunun anlamı neydi bizim
için? Veya bağlacı değil mi? E bu veya
bağlacı aslında nerede kullanılıyor?
Birleşim kümesinde. Bu da birleşim
anlamına geliyor. P'nin değili hani
dedim ya az önce tümleyen kümesi gibi
düşün dedik. A kümesinin tümleyeni gibi.
Biz normalde P'nin doğruluk değerini
yazarken P denktir 1 veya işte Q denktir
0 gibi yazıyoruz. Arkadaş tabii ki
kümelerde denkliyi kullanmıyoruz.
Eşittir sembolünü kullanıyoruz. Yani
oradaki sembollerin karşılığını bilmekte
fayda var. Peki hocam iyi güzel de yani
burası gerçekten sözel ve hani böyle
sanki biraz havada kaldı gibi. Sorularda
bunu hissetmeyeceksin. Gel şimdi
sorularını çözmeye başlayalım. Sadece şu
her ve bazıyı biraz ayırmayı öğrenmemiz
lazım. Yukarıdaki önermelerden kaç
tanesi doğrudur? Türkçe oku. Her x
elemanıdır reel sayı için x kare 0'dan
büyüktür. Önce ne demek istediğini gel
beraber yorumlayalım. Her x elemanı reel
sayı. Reel sayılar yani gerçek sayılarda
seçtiğin bütün her diyor evrensel
hepsini kastediyor. Sayıların karesi
0dan büyüktür. Mesela deneyesin geliyor
değil mi? Hemen dur ulan hocam bir
deneyeyim işte -1in karesi 1dir. 0'dan
büyüktür. 5in karesi işte 25'tir 0'dan
büyüktür. -√3ün karesi 3'tür. Karesi
tabii ki 0'dan büyük çıktı. E hocam yok
mu? Var. 0ın karesi 0 bir reel sayıdır
dikkat edersen.
0ın karesi
0dan pardon her sayının karesi 0'dan
büyüktür. Al. Büyük mü? Değil aslında.
Eşit. O zaman yanlış. O zaman ne diyorum
biliyor musun? Evrensel niceleyicinin
doğru ya da yanlış olduğunu ispatlamak
için eğer ki yanlış olduğunu ispatlamak
istiyorsan özellikle bir tane bak
yüzlerce binlerce ben sana doğru örnek
verebilirim. Sadece bir tane
veremiyorum. 0ın karesi 0. Ya hocam bir
taneden bir şey olmaz deriz. Biz de hep
adettendir öyle derler ya. Olur arkadaş.
Her diye lafını ediyorsan olur. O yüzden
nedir bu ifade? Yanlış bir önermedir.
Anlaştık mı? Nedenini anlattım. Bir tane
bile yanlış örnek göstersem yeter. Her
bağlacında. O zaman istersen bunu not
düşelim be. Her niceleyicisinde
her
niceleyicisinde niceleyicisinde
bir tane bile yanlış gösterirsen bir
tane bile yanlış göstermek yanlış
göstermek
yeterli.
Not düştük mü bunu? Tabii yanlışlığını
göstermeye çalışıyorsan yeterli. Bir
tane bile yanlış. Her x elemanıdır doğal
sayı için. X'ler 0'a eşit veya 0'dan
büyüktür. Ne diyor? Doğal sayıların
hepsi demek istiyor. Ya 0a eşittir ya
0'dan büyüktür. Kesinlikle doğru hocam.
Çünkü doğal sayı dediğin şey zaten 0'dan
başlıyor. 0 1 2 nokta nokta gidiyor ya.
Benim doğal sayılarda kimi seçersem
seçeyim şunu sağlamıyor mu? Ya 0a
eşittir ya 0'dan büyüktür. Güzel. Bu
ifade doğru oldu. Geldim. Nasıl
okuyorduk? En az bir tane tam sayı
vardır. X - 2 = 1/3 denkleminin
eşitliğini sağlar. Gel bunu beraber
gösterelim. Şimdi en az bir tane tam
sayı bulmam lazım. Bu x yerine öyle bir
tam sayı yazacaksın ki cevap 1/3
gelecek. Hocam bu bir denklem. Biz bu
denklemi çözeriz diyorsun değil mi? Bu
denklemi sağlayan bir tane x değeri var.
Nedir o? Hemen bakalım. 1/3 karşıya + 2
olarak geçti. Toplamayı yaptım. 6 1 daha
7/3 Bir dakika bu denklemi sağlayan bir
tane x değeri var ama o sağlayan x
değeri tam sayı değil. Bu ne demek
istiyor? Bir tane var diyor. En az bir
tane var. Belki birden fazla da vardır
diyor ama en az bir tane vardır diyor.
Bunu sağlayan tam sayı abiciğim. Bir
tane sağlayan var. O da tam sayı değil
yani. Yanlış. Anlaştık mı? Detaylı
anlatıma devam. Her x elemanıdır reel
sayı için x² = 9.
X yerine hangi reel sayıyı yazarsan yaz
9'a eşit çıkar diyor. Karesi. Öyle bir
dünyan var mı? Yok. O zaman ne
yapıyorsun? Bir tane bile yanlış
göstermem yeterli. O zaman geldim her
bağlacı için bir tane yanlış göstermeye
çalışıyorum. X diyorum işte yani bir x
değeri seçelim istersen. 1'i seçtim abi.
1 elemanı mıdır reel sayı? Evet. 1in
karesi kaçtır hocam? 1dir. Eşit midir
9'a? Değildir. Ama sen diyorsun eşit
olacak diyorsun. Seçtiğin bütün sayılar
nereye eşit? değil işte. Bir tane bile
yanlış gösterdiğim için elendi. Şimdi
ikinci bir not daha düşelim bence
buraya. Bazı en az bir niceleyicisinde
niceleyicisinde
bir tane bile doğru göstersen bir tane
bile doğru göstersen göstermek yeterli.
Göstermek yeterli. Tamam mı? Senden bunu
istiyorum. Niye? En az bir tane diyor.
Bir tane göster diyor. Yeter benim için
diyor. Geldim 5 numaraya. 5 numara ne
diyor? Birlikte okuyalım. Bak bunları
okumak çok kıymetli. Matematik adına en
az bir tane x doğal sayısı vardır. Bu
denklemi bu eşitsizliği özür dilerim
sağlar. Hocam tek deneyelim. Ne sağlar
bulalım. Denemene gerek yok. Bak önce
eşitsizliği çöz. Aldım karşıya attım. 4.
Peki 4'ten küçük olan doğal sayılar 0 1
2 3 değil mi? 4 tane eleman bu çözüm
kümesini sağlıyor hocam. Ve bu
sağlayanlardan en az bir tanesi doğal
sayı mı? Hepsi doğal sayı. Bir tanesinin
bile doğal sayı olması yetiyordu ama
sağlıyor mu? Misal 0'ı yerine yazdım. -1
<< Bitti. 0 nedir? 0 elemanıdır. Doğal
sayı. Bir tane bile sağlayan buldun mu
bu bağlaç için yeterlidir. Senden bunu
istiyor aslında mantıken. 48. sayfamızda
böylelikle adım adım sayfaları bitirmeye
devam ediyorum. Bak ne oldu? 272
sayfaydı. 2inci sayfadan başladık. 48'i
gitti. Bir sonraki sayfa. Biliyorum bir
sayfayı 20 dakikada yaptık farkındayım
ama derinlemesini öğrenmek için
yapıyorum. Bunu her seferinde
hatırlatacağım. Hocam yetiştirebilir
miyiz diye çok soru geliyor gençler.
Gerçekten şunu söyleyeyim. Ben bir yere
bir şey yetiştirmeye çalışmıyorum.
Süratle araba kullanmaya çalışmıyorum.
Elimden geldiğince günde daha fazla
video ama senin de bitirebileceğini göz
önünde bulundurarak ve Eylül ayında
bitmesini planlayarak, Eylül ayı
içerisinde birinde değil içerisinde
bitmeyi planlayarak bu kampa devam
ediyoruz. Kolay bir şey değil. İki tane
kitap bitiriyorsun burada 2.000 küsür
soru olacak bittiğinde. 2.000 küsür
soruyu ayda 1000 soru yapar arkadaşlar
zaten. Değil mi? Sizin için söylüyorum.
Kendim için değil. Ben bir şekilde
çekeceğim videoları.
Eğer gerçekten hem öğrenerek zaten bak
bir tane videonun süresi 25 30 dakika
bile olsa senin onu bitirmen yaklaşık
bir saatleri bazen buluyor. Açıp film
gibi izlemiyorsun sundur inşallah.
Hadi devam. Aşağıda sözel dil olarak
verilen ifadeleri sembolik dille
belirtmeye yazmaya çalışacağız. Şimdi az
önce hani okuyordum ya ben sana her x
elemanı. Hah onu matematiğe çevireceğiz.
Okunmuş hali. Sanki biri okuyormuş gibi
düşün. Her çift doğal sayının şimdi her
çift doğal sayının bir kere doğal sayı
var değil mi? Her x elemanı olsun doğal
sayı ve x'ler ne olacak? Çift doğal
sayı. Doğal doğal sayı dememe gerek yok.
Çift olacak. Ne de olsa doğal sayı
olduğunu belirttim. X'ler çift olacak.
Karesi çift sayıdır. X² çifttir.
Çifttir. Bu arada bunların tek bir
çözümü yok. Farklı şekillerde
gösterilebilirler arkadaşlar. Mesela her
x elemanıdır doğal sayı. X = 2k iken x²
çifttir. Böyle de gösterebilirsin. Tabii
k'ye de tam sayı yazmam lazım. K
elemanıdır. Z parantez yok. Çift nokta
var. Şöyle yani farklı gösterimler var
ama sonuç olarak benzer şeye çıkmamız
lazım. Bak bunla bu aynı aslında. X
elemanın doğal sayı. X elemanın doğal
sayı her. Tamam. X 2K demek çift sayı
demek. Eğer k tam sayıysa e x'e direkt
çift de diyebilirsin. Iken x kare
çifttir. X kare çifttir. Bitti. Aynı
şeyi söylüyoruz aslında. Tamam. Gel
bakalım. Bazı doğal sayıların karesi
15'ten küçüktür. Yazalım. Bak bazıyı
nasıl yazıyorduk? En az 1. Bazı aynı
şöyle yazılıyordu. X doğal sayıları X
elemanı olacak. Doğal sayı karesi bu
X'in karesi 15'ten küçük olacak. Üç 15.
Bitti. Bak matematik sembolleriyle
yazdık.
En az bir tam sayının en az bir bazı
sembolü buydu değil mi? En az bir x
elemanıdır. Tam sayı dediği için buraya
artık z koyuyorum. Buraya kadar yazdım.
3 katının 6 eksiği 3 katının 6 eksiği 2
katından küçüktür. 2x'ten küçüktür.
Bitti. Ne diyorsa onu yazıyorum.
Gördüğümü yazmaya çalışıyorum. Bütün
gerçek sayıların karesi pozitiftir.
Bütün her anlamına geliyor değil mi? Her
x elemanıdır. Gerçek sayı neydi? Reel.
Gerçek. Aynı şey r ile gösteriliyordu.
Karesi pozitiftir. Pozitif ne demek? Üf
demektir. Matematikte biz öyle
gösteriyoruz. Pozitifi. Her gerçek
sayının mutlak değeri her gerçek sayının
mutlak değeri 0dan büyüktür. Ne diyorsa
onu yazıyoruz.
Bazı tam sayılar burası önemli olduğu
için bazı tam sayılar 3'ten büyüktür
veya her doğal sayı pozitiftir. Oradaki
veya artık mantık sembolü ile yazılmak
zorunda. Bazı sembolünü koyacağız değil
mi? Bazı en az bir x elemanıdır. Tam
sayısı için bu sayılar 3'ten büyüktür. X
> 3'ten veya bağlacı neydi? Yukarıya
doğru V harfiydi. Bağlaçların sembolleri
bilinecek. eşit eşittir diyorum. Devam
ediyorum. Hatta bunları artık böyle
şöyle parantezle de gösterirler. Birden
fazla önerme yan yana geldiğinde
bağlaçta bağlandığında her doğal sayı
pozitiftir. Her x elemanıdır doğal sayı
x > 0. Tamam mı? Bir yani bağlaçla
bağlanan önermeleri böyle parantezli
gösterebiliriz.
Her doğal sayı negatif değilse aslında
bunun Türkçesi nasıl yazılır? değil ise
ise bağlacıdır arkadaşlar. Bu her doğal
sayı negatif değilse bir sayı negatif
değilse nedir? Burası ince. Bir sayı
negatif değilse ya 0'a eşittir ya da
0dan büyüktür. İkisini birden nasıl
gösterirsin? Tabii ki böyle göstersin. Ü
eş 0. Arkadaşlar bakın burası önemli.
Bir daha söylüyorum. Her doğal sayı
negatif değilse negatif değilse nedir?
Bu sayı matematikte nasıl gösterilir?
negatif değilse ya 0dır ya 0'dan
büyüktür. Ya 0d ya 0'dan büyüktürüm de
matematiksel kıtı sembolü bu. Geldim
arada ne bağlacı var? İse bağlacı var.
Açtım ise sağa doğru oku. Sola doğru
yapma. Her doğal sayının karesi Her
doğal sayının karesi 0dan büyüktür.
Karesi 0dan büyüktür. Bitti. En az bir
tam sayı. Bak en az bir tam sayı 3'ten
küçüktür. x3'ten küçüktür. Kapadım
parantez bağlaca baktım. Ancak ve ancak
ancak ve ancak gerektirme değil mi?
Sağlı sollu bağlacımı yani ancak ve
ancak bağlacını koyuyorum. Her doğal
sayının karesi her doğal sayının karesi
0dan büyüktür. Ne diyorsa onu yazıyorum.
Ne diyorsa onu yazıyorum. Evet. En başta
zorlayacaktır
ama zamanla anlaşacağız. Gel bakalım.
Aşağıda tabloda verilen önermelerin
değillerini yazınız. Şimdi o sembollerle
verilerin hani o sembollerin değilleri
nasıl olur diye anlattım ya bir ön
sayfada. Onları yazmaya çalışacağız
beraber. Ne diyor? Her x elemanıdır
n'nin. Hocam başlıyorum. Herin değili
neydi? X elemanıdır n'nin. Şunu
diyebilirsin hocam. Niye elemanı
değildir yazmıyorsun? Burada yazılmıyor
arkadaşlar. Burada sadece niceli
değiştiriliyor. Tamam mı? x + 1 x + 1
küçürün değili neydi? Ü eşitti ü eş 5
bitti. Her x elemanıdır. Heridin
niceleyicisinin değeli neydi? Pardon en
az bir nicelicisinin değili neydi?
Herdi. Her x elemanıdır r ve x - 5
dikkat et ü eş 3 diyor. Üç 3. eşittirin
neden küçüktür olduğunu bir önceki
sayfada anlattım. Şimdi uyguluyorum.
Geldim. Her x elemanıdır z diyor. En az
1 x elemanıdır z. x² + 1 eş değildir 7
diyor. E değili nedir? Eşittir 7.
En az 1 x elemanıdır diyor. Ben her x
elemanıdır. R mutlak değerce x > 4
diyor. Üktürün değili eş 4 diyeceğim.
Olayı bitireceğim. Geldim yoluma devam
ettim. Güzel bir ispat yapacağız burada.
Gerçekten hoşumuza giden bir ispat.
Aşağıda Ayl öğretmenin tahtaya yazdığı
bir soru görseli verilmiş. Bir tam
sayının karesi ile kendisinin toplamı
her zaman çift sayıya eşittir. Bir tam
hep çift sayıymış. İspatını yapınız.
Öğrencilerden Necati'nin yaptığı ispat
adımları aşağıdaki gibidir. Buna göre
Necati'nin yaptığı işlem adımlarından
hata olup olmadığını, hata varsa ilk kez
hangi adımda hata yaptığına bakınız. Tek
tek adım adım okuyacağız aslında. Okuma
sorusu. Tam sayı x olsun. X bir tam
sayı. Yani n de elemanları bir tam sayı
olsun. Kabul. X diyor ki ya 2n'dir ya 2n
+ 1'dir. Burada ne demeye çalışıyor şair
bize? Şunu demeye çalışıyor. N tam
sayıyken 2 ile çarptığım bütün tam
sayılar çifttir. Diyor ki x burada çift
olsun. X çift olsun demek istiyor. X
çift
olsun veya x ne olsun? 2n + 1 de tek
sayıları sembolize eder. Tek olsun demek
istiyor. Zaten x bir tam sayıysa ya tek
tam sayıdır ya çift tam sayıdır. Doğru
mu? Diyor ki önce onu bir belirleyelim.
2n'yi bundan sonra çift olarak 2n + 1'i
tek olarak alacağım diyor. Tamam. X
diyor eğer 2n ise çift sayıysa xin
karesi 2n'nin parantez karesi demektir.
Doğru. Karesini aldı. 4 kare 2in karesi
4. N'nin karesi ne kare? Bu da doğru. X²
+ X karesi ile kendisinin toplamı.
kendisi 2n karesi 4n² topluyorum diyor
ama diyor ben bunu diyor 2 parantezine
alırım ki diyor hatta 2n parantezine
alır da sadece 2 parantezine alıyor
sıkıntı yok n + 2n² ifadesi çift sayıdır
doğru mu değil mi doğru neden bak 2 çift
bir sayı bunu bilmiyorsan bile çiftle
neyi çarparsan çarp tam sayı anlamında
cevap yine ne gelir çift sayı gelir o
zaman bu doğruydu bu arada bu da
doğrudur hocam yola demem acaba nerede
hata var 3ün 3 adım. Şimdi x = 2n için
teoremi ispatladı. Şimdi geldi 2n + 1
için tek sayıyı kabul etti. X'in
karesini alması lazım. 2n + 1in karesi
parantez karesi 1incinin karesi 1inci
ile ikincinin çarpımının 2 katı
ikincinin karesi açılım budur. Tam kare
hafı iadelerin açılımlarını daha sonra
da göstereceğim. Şimdilik sadece takip
ediyorum ama doğru. X² + X karesi ile
kendisinin toplamına bakacak. kendisi 2n
+ 1 karesi 4n² + 4n + 1 dedi ki gel
bunları toplayalım. Topladım 4n² 6n + 2
çıktı. Güzel hepsi 2 parantezine
alınabiliyor diye aldım diyor 2
parantezine artık diyor ben bu olayı
çözdüm diyor. Bak diyor 2 diyor çift
sayıdır diyor. Buradan ne geldiğinin bir
önemi yok benim için diyor. Çift bir
sayıyla tam sayıyı çarparsan cevap daima
çift sayı gelir. Gerçekten doğrudur. O
zaman hocam 3üncü adımda hata yoksa 4te
mi var? N elemanıdır Z iken x kare + x
her zaman çift sayıdır. Teoremi
ispatlandı. Bitti. Çünkü bütün adımlarda
tek tek sayı olduğunda, çift sayı
olduğunda hepsini de gösterdi. Demek ki
gerçekten bu ifade doğrudur. Yoktur
arkadaşlar. Hata yok. Nasıl yani hocam?
Bir şey yok mu? Hata yoktur. Ne? Alıştın
değil mi böyle sorularda hata çıkmasına?
Bu da bizden sana bir ters köşe olsun
diye yazılmış bir soruydu. 49. sayfada
efendim biter. Böylelikle 50. sayfaya
sayı kümelerinde kaldığımız yerden işlem
özelliklerine bu sefer devam ediyor
olacağız. İnşallah güzel kampımız da
senin için de güzel gidiyordur diyelim.
Arkadaşım ben yoluma devam edeceğim.
Malumunuz yine yoğun bir şekilde
videolar gelmeye devam edecek. Günün
ikinci videoları olsun hepsi. İnşallah
çok güzel sorular da çözüyor olacağız
devam eden günlerde. Ama bazen konular
üslü, köklü, mutlak değer gibi çok
zevkli olmuyor bile. Böyle şeyler de
yapacağız. Hadi bakalım. Kendine çok iyi
bak. Hoş kal. Hoşça kalın.